boa tarde senhoras e senhores boa tarde
senhora do governo
ah vou contar um pouco da minha história
como sendo um membro da comunidade lgbt
em cabo verde como sendo uma modelo free
diana e principalmente como sendo a mim
tragédia era cabo verde a tudo começou
já há alguns anos atrás alguns anos
atrás
atualmente tenho 25 anos e atualmente
tenho 25 anos a há muitos anos atrás
obviamente já criança mamede cobrir a
por sérgio é um pouco diferente das
outras crianças a com qual brincava a
pronto estava coisas diferentes gostava
de fazer brincadeiras diferentes algumas
vezes até nem gostava de correr com os
rapazes brincar de power rangers a força
suprema essas cenas todas o rapaz bem
inúmeras vezes ninguém ficava mais em
brincar com bonecas a penteados roupas é
tetra pronto com o passar do ano fui
crescendo a aviamento que não foi nada
fácil já por ter nascido dentro de uma
família muito religiosa
os meus tios são diretores e
responsáveis folha por departamentos de
entender e dentro da igreja nazarena a
antão por intuito não foi uma coisa
muito fácil e também por eu já ter
nascido dentro de uma doutrina religiosa
a freqüentava os curtos participava dos
grupos corais fazia coreografias tocava
instrumentos musicais
ainda assim a
entender a via ao tava errado não por eu
tarde dentro da igreja ou portar vai
portar a fazer algo a portar a louvar a
deus não simplesmente por hora em
algumas coisas não me ficava
honestamente a com o passar dos anos fui
eu fui marie descobrindo não é a idéia é
sair com com já com alguma idade
estudava no liceu no seu pedro gomes na
época já pretendia compensar uma crise
nervosa a pronto vovô ar um pouquinho
para trás assim em portando a a ao tema
religioso
algumas vezes eu saía nos finais de
semana e pronto aquilo de um jovem essa
ir a festas eram bebidas tudo aquilo que
não era de acordo com a doutrina
religiosa
aí no domingo sábado no domingo não
levantava de manhã ea procura 29 a e
éramos éramos éramos um número bastante
grande de jovens que faziam a mesma
coisa passava e saímos no domingo
iríamos a igreja tem uma música que é k
ainda maior
ainda está na memória que é irmão você
também é uma tensão para mim então
aquilo todo cuidávamos na na mão do
outro pra ser irmão você também uma
bênção para mim mas dentro do meio jovem
aquilo não era muito não era muito não
era verdade vamos dizer assim porque na
sexta e no sábado falavam mal um do
outro e no domingo em alvalade ser irmão
você também é uma bênção para mim
foram coisas que eu fui eu fui eu fui eu
fui preparado eu fui eu fui vendo
algumas coisas que não não me agradava
após o meu batismo aliás a decisão final
veio depois meu batismo abac sair no
domingo de manhã e no domingo à noite já
estava na festa ea então eu disse lhe
não meu deus vai fazer comigo
pronto sempre nas entrevistas sempre na
amm em perguntar não há sexo alguma
coisa policial
o curto acredita principalmente existe
um ser supremo existe deus sim acredito
que ela está aqui dentro de mim não é
por eu ter feito as minhas escolhas não
é por eu ter nascido da forma que eu
nasci cá não vou acreditar em deus mas
seguindo a no liceu na época do liceu
sempre fui a um jovem khan foi de
inúmeras coisas
em uma delas foi obtido em ser
presidente da associação de estudantes
mas isso os vices e tornar a principal
são estudantes de seguir adquirindo a
longo prazo
fiz planos a longo prazo e pronta também
porque tornar apresenta a seção
estudantes da escola secundária pedro
gomes tomado um jovem canção jovem khan
nem essa coisas faz planos a longo prazo
isso interessa sim a já sabia que ao ser
previsível diante do tre e até de
benefícios no futuro e domingo
acertei a pronto fiz trabalhos como
presidente da associação de estudantes
a ajuda de inúmeros alunos fez trabalhos
pra fora da doença também mas estava em
abrir muitas portas para ser conhecida
em cabo verde o que é o confronto era
realmente o que ama o que mais me
interessava ser conhecida para ainda das
barreiras que existiam entre policial
com isso muitas pessoas não consideram
por causa dos eventos inicialmente que o
que organizava que demandava os repentes
até que ame descobriram como modelo
nunca que ser mulher primeiramente nunca
quis ser mais uma das coisas que eu fiz
por saber que ainda não podia também
lutar um pouco mais à frente do que eu
tava no momento foi um tanto muitas
pessoas não ganhasse o que foi aquilo
que foi muito fácil mas não foi
ah eu tive uma certa insegurança em
relação a isso numa época onde me
apoiavam outros me jogavam uns colocavam
as mãos nos poços outro me apunhalaram
pelas costas mas pronto eu continuar
seguindo na mesma época quando o
conceito filar a gera no início da
puberdade avaí no início da minha
verdade já estavam começar a crescer
alguns pêlos na cara bigot digamos assim
a mas ainda assim já tinha alguns traços
bastante femininos onde esse traço é um
em corda ter uma vez que a minha mãe
perguntou ó boquita foi quando na mala'
aqui político tem a e eu não eu não
sabia o que estava a acontecer do
momento na época eu não sabia o que
estava acontecendo e em trouxeram
algumas algumas dificuldades e voar
algumas crises estavam um pouco das
pessoas mas pronto
continuando a seguir na época não me
vestia de mulher
mesmo sendo um modelo não tinha mulher
em uma vez em uma festa numa discoteca
não vou citar o nome de hipoteca a
pediram kan dois amigos gás a dançar
normalmente na pista impediram aquele
onde está isso não pode acontecer
vamos transmitir
agora quero a minha forma de projeto de
protesto
ok a colocava longos cabelos vermelhos
até a costa a ahab enormes saltos destes
bichinhos a mais uma coisa que eu não
fazia era irar buço não tirava o bbb 11
é o bigode
isso sim era a cara da manifestação era
mostrar que eu posso ter um corpo que eu
posso saber andar com uma peça de roupa
feminina pode cair bem mas ainda assim
eu tinha uns eu tinha bigode até também
teve uma vez que eu estava no encostar
ao bairro senhor foi lavar pelas costas
a ii festa bonita mas quando eu virei
com ele eo bigode ele se desculpa por
falar mas continua sendo bonita então
nisso de desejo de manifestar protestar
numa noite a tentar uma bloquear
bloquearam a minha entrada nessa
discoteca a até foi a minha cara na
época eu não ia entrar nessa disputa eca
por portar portar vestida de forma
inadequada
a palavra correta é inadequada pronto
sempre foi um sempre uma pessoa que
gostei muito da de saber da laís
principalmente quanto féria é leis leis
que vão contra algum membro da
comunidade lgbt
a então joguei no telemóvel chamei para
um político liguei para a polícia
explicando que estava a acontecer na
porta da discoteca
mas antes disso tentei inúmeras vezes
falar com o dono da discoteca mandava
responder mandava ter a porta e não que
ele não estava dentro da discoteca mas
quando os policiais chegaram o dono da
discoteca sair diretamente dentro da
equipe técnica e corresponder um
policial mas a eu porque eu já tinha
chamado é porque tava aí eu não estava
mas não tinha mas não tinha mais
entradas eram de entradas
eu não vim para passar por uma guerra
direta ela saiu de lá dentro e veio pra
fora
os policiais eram a cam que eu não
entrasse dentro da festa
a discoteca teria ser puxada acho que
foi o primeiro o primeiro ganho que eu
tive o primeiro respeito mesmo a sério e
eu tive de partir da de leis a foi foi o
primeiro foi o primeiro o primeiro chip
a seguindo já me conhecia melhor agora
já tava ver até mais transformações no
meu corpo do que antes
quanto mais grande quando uma quanto
mais de dar eu tenho mais o meu corpo
transforma
podem perguntar se eu já tenho uma meta
se não se eu já mandei tem uma mesa
cirúrgica
não não não me deitei um dia talvez mas
por agora não mas tem inúmeras coisas no
meu corpo é um são naturalmente meninas
e algumas outras eu fui modificando com
o tratamento hormonal
eu faço a pronto teve uma vez também não
caiu
jajá maioridade já assim era parecer
pronto e descobriram como modelo tranjan
andrógena poderia desfilar também um
homem como mulher tem uma certa
dificuldade em se tratando de um homem
porque não tinham nascido alguns já
tinha tido início amigos na época mas
ainda assim dava para desfilar e
conseguindo sentar um pouco atrapalhada
desculpei e fui seguindo a inúmeras diz
filhos mas como eu disse que não era não
era por vontade e portar apostar mas
cinco é o saber que eram novos até era
um evento abriam certas portas porque em
cabo verde lamentavelmente pode ter um
diploma
bola mas se não conhecerem muito
dificilmente vão te dar trabalho
eu vi senti isso na pele
em cena na pele principalmente por ser
uma transgênera isso na tela acredito
que até por ser da comunidade lgbt acaba
por se tornar mais difícil elas darem
crédito de trabalho mas ainda assim ter
só alguém alguém confia em mim que é a
minha a minha chefe
ana margarida conde comecei a trabalhar
na primeira produções como como
produtora das campanhas a a os dez efe e
17 finais de set inicial 18 anos comecei
a trabalhar na primeira como produtora
das campanhas publicitárias
fui seguindo até o dia de hoje não têm
informação alguma na área não tem
informação alguma na área mas aprendi
tudo o que aprendi
uram de acordo com os anos de trabalho
que eu fui desenvolvendo também cheguei
a trabalhar com eventos há atualmente
sou dono da minha própria empresa
microempresa caras
quando me perguntam sobre claras quando
me perguntam sobre cargas e eu respondo
caras caras porque porque trabalho com
imagem imagem trabalho com atores
modelos e atores modelos apras campanhas
publicitárias e trabalha também com
protocolos para os grandes eventos e
graças a deus tem sido uma coisa boa e
tenho conseguido inúmeros trabalhos com
isso graças a deus sobre o cérebro
android sobre sobre sobre permite
transgénero cabo verde agora lamentável
muitos eventos da comunidade lgbt não
são muito muito bem visto muito menos
apoiado aqui em cabo verde e na praia
então já nem existe porque talvez tensa
há mais repercussão e
e mais assistência mais público e
principalmente mais apoio e deste ano e
do ano passado 2007 quando eu parei que
isso não acontece
mas quando cheguei aqui mais uma vez
também não queria ter me vim pra que
prontamente e insisti e insistirei toca
aí vem pra que há sempre brincava no
camarim foi mesmo que um eventual
aumento aconteceu mesmo aqui no camarim
logo atrás eu sempre estava a brincar
com as outras candidatas foquem no
cheque foquem no check ok no cheque
acho que também podia ser a minha forma
de tentar descontrair do estresse de vir
subir aqui para lutar por uma coroa mas
acaba por ser miss
só que diferente das outras missas das
minhas já das minhas antes horas
eu queria fazer algo mais porque das
outras que eu me lembre não tiveram não
tiveram oportunidade de seguir mais
adiante se calhar por cantar vez por
desinteresse talvez por falta de apoio
mas eu elaborei número um e número de
projetos inúmeros projetos sobre a
comunidade lgbt e não só os meus
projetos basicamente são para ser
realizado na capital como irá acabar por
diana em si com foco na comunidade lgbt
ainda torna a luta cheguei a falar com
algumas pessoas chegam a fazer a
apresentação do meu projeto
para algumas pessoas a lamentavelmente
ainda tentou sem sucesso algum também
tentou pegar uma coroa a maçã não vou
desistir tem mais alguns meses de
reinado
espero conseguir chegar lá sobre
preconceito em 11 anos
a aposta a perguntar se eu já sofri
preconceito e prova isso foi aquele ano
na discoteca mas já vi inúmeros inúmeras
a serem abaterem agride fisicamente e
verbalmente com pedras
garrafas com palavras a eu não nunca
nunca cheguei a passar por nada do tipo
mas posso colocar no lugar de deus posso
sentir a dor deus a dor a dor que elas
já passaram
acredito não ser uma coisa aqui não é
uma coisa fácil de suportar se calhar
pronto pra vocês
pode ser uma mapa pode ser um pode ser
uma um gol será algo pronto khan
sim não não vou conseguir achar a
palavra certa mas pode ser uma dori
mas para nós não é algo campo muitas
vezes acaba por nos obrigará a nos
fechar da sociedade goiana pronto gente
meu tempo acabou
espero que tenha entendido lamentável em
tom pouco confusa tudo muito confuso
imitasse muito nervosa
espero na próxima oportunidade se calhar
fizerem algumas perguntas eu poder
responder mais uma vez obrigado por não
terem convidado
boa tarde